do you know who drew afuelo is I'm
hot I do not I've never heard of this
person before in my life but producer
Jacob being 12 years old a very hip cool
young Zoomer he insists that I bear the
pain of watching some Drew afuelo Tick
Tock videos drifwelo is allegedly an
influencer and podcast with almost 8
million followers on Tick Tock she
primarily makes content roasting men
sure she does who she believes have used
that are misogynistic fat phobic
and producer Jacob I don't know I guess
he hates me I guess he thinks that I
roast him too much so he's going to make
me endure this this video is brought to
you by expressvpn more from expressvpn
in a moment for now though let's get
started with MS of wallow
teacher
but I'm pretty sure the definition of
that is uh poor
God
good one you're right you are definitely
not a teacher but you could be a lima
bean why is your head shaped like that
Jesus you got a lot on your mind or what
the men who say this don't even Crest
80k a year
what are you worried about and even if
she was a hoe she's not your hoe what
are you worried about the dudes who say
that they are always broke and
complaining about women after their
fictional money sounds like you're
hating from outside the club
also a nose ring at your fossil age okay
also you look like the main baby from
Coco melon oh bye look I drew a beard
too
bye I I get why she's popular I get it's
a laugh it's all the laughs
it might be a genuine laugh or it's at
least a shtick that is pretty funny and
it's so many layers right it's a video
reacted to in a video reacted to in a
video reacted to in a video none of
which conveyed any
real information but taken together it's
like hyper reality you know taken
together it's so condensed so dense
every single image such a pure grade A
concentrative Commentary that it's it's
kind of amusing I get it they say like
oh men men are meant to protect
protect from what because we're not
cavemen anymore so you're not fighting
sabertooth tigers protect from what and
then it's like y'all aren't y'all aren't
useful when this other man accosting us
that's why I said protect from what
other men yeah it turns out you're the
root of all evil but then even when you
do see like something happening you
don't do anything yeah I've seen several
videos of women getting like abused or
assaulted like in public and manner just
stand around like you usually do
recording it yeah not knowing and doing
nothing else but why would I step into
an altercation that has nothing to do
with me
because I don't know maybe you have a
moral compass yeah you know like when we
get knocked out well you said provide
and protect
they've almost got a point there they
like don't have a point and then they
kind of have a point but then they lose
their Point again they don't have a
point in that men are the stronger sex
and women need to be protected and if
men were not there to protect women uh
through law enforcement and through
family than women would be quite
vulnerable to uh predation yes I
thought that was obvious just a fact of
human nature and then she says well men
are the root of all evil because you're
protecting women from other men but
you're also protecting women from other
women because man is one species and men
and women are the two Sexes of the
species but man refers to both sexes so
you'd say in the beginning God created
man both male and female created he them
so I get maybe they're a little confused
by that by language but she says well
men are the root of all evil that's
that's not true but it's true that human
nature is Fallen but Human Nature has
fallen for both men and women as I think
they would demonstrate but then then she
says well sometimes men just stand
around and they don't protect women
sometimes men just stand around and
they'll film or you know even if a
woman's being attacked and and sometimes
that is true part of that is a political
problem though because sometimes men do
intervene so for instance when a crazy
career criminal with the rap sheet a
mile long comes onto a Subway and tells
people including women I'm going to kill
you I don't care if I die I'm going to
kill you and then a man a Marine stands
up and takes that threat out well that
man is going to go to prison that man is
going to be brought up on homicide
charges and many of the liberal women
who are here complaining about how the
men don't ever stand up and defend them
they're going to be the ones to cry
racism and call the man a murderer and
say he shouldn't have stood up and done
anything so there's a political problem
here which is that the political order
incentivizes men not to act not to
protect people so that's true it's a
little bit damned if you do damned if
you don't aspect here right now go to
expressvpn.com Michael YT it is
extremely important to protect your
online privacy with a VPN choosing a VPN
that you trust
equally important I can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market here is why number one
expressvpn doesn't log your online
activity they've even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all
2. speed expressvpn does not slow down
your user experience you can even stream
HD videos with zero buffering number
three expressvpn is incredibly easy to
use just fire up the app and tap one
button to connect it's not just me
saying this Business Insider The Verge
many other Tech journals great
expressvpn the number one VPN in the
world protect yourself with the VPN that
I trust use my link expressvpn.com
michaelyt today get three months free in
one year package
expresvpn.com Michael YT letter y letter
T expressvpn.com Michael YT head on over
there today men who complain about gold
diggers they have no gold they have no
money what are you worried about you're
worried about other men's money that's
crazy stack your own bread before you
worry about somebody else's I can't tell
you how many how many men I've stitches
that are like see this is why you gotta
worry about these gold
what show me a W-2 I want to see how
much money you made last year and I'll
tell you if you should be worried about
gold diggers don't worry about it I
promise you're okay you're safe don't
worry women like that only date like
it's high Echelon men like top tier like
money would never even be you can't even
think of the number you can't even
imagine the number and like women only
date men like that so they're not
looking at you working at Jiffy Lube
like I promise you're good I promise
you're safe it's a kind of funny
observation it's just not true women who
don't have class or dignity occasionally
are able to NAB a billionaire but
usually cannot and so those kinds of
women will prey on men who are not
billionaires so you're basically saying
that you're just dating me because I can
buy you things yes
if you are Jeff Bezos you could date a
gold digger it doesn't matter Paul
McCartney could date a gold digger and
marry a gold digger it doesn't really
matter these guys have practically
speaking Limitless well but if you're a
regular guy who who doesn't have a ton
of money This Woman's still going to
make fun of that guy said you don't have
any money your Point's kind of funny and
she's making fun of these guys and it's
cruel humor but from the operation of
how a gold digger actually works that
it's just it just isn't true why don't
women like short men right okay one side
of it could be beauty standards who made
those other men okay other men are the
ones who have said you have to be tall
to be considered manly that's because of
y'all that's one two we'll put a pause
right there see what what she does
that's incoherent and she says I am
independent minded I'm I'm smarter than
all of you people you need to listen to
me I see things correctly I'm an
empowered woman I set the rules I do
whatever I want but also men have all
the control and they're the only people
with agency and women can't do anything
do you see the conflict there do you see
that problem which is not just her
problem it's an incoherence at the heart
of feminism women have absolutely no
control or agency to set beauty
standards to to do anything at all and
also women have all the agency and
Independence in the world and they don't
need a man and a woman needs a man like
a fish needs a bicycle I'm a woman hear
me roar
a lot of times short men are horrible
totally why because they have What's
called the Napoleon complex look it up
if you don't know yeah short man
syndrome that's literally a
psychological thing that they have
because they're toxic masculinity has
entrenched them in this hatred towards
themselves totally so they act out and a
lot of times they're extremely
misogynistic or bigoted in general or
they're just downright terrible but she
has a decent Point here just short guys
can be awful that's true she's going
obviously too far in that direction
she's saying short men because they're
short or have all these sort of
psychopathologies and therefore they're
really terrible and that's not true but
short guys can be just as bad as tall
guys but just like fat women can be just
as bad as skinny women poor kids are
just as bright and just as tall as white
kids you can be awful
in any condition that you're in and you
can also be Sanctified in any any
condition that you're in some of the
greatest men of history have been pretty
short some of the greatest men in
history have been pretty sure does that
does that mean that every man over six
feet is not awful no not even a little
even a little bit but a lot of times if
women are like okay well if I'm gonna if
they're all bad if they're all trash I
want to date a tall piece of trash like
if you're all gonna be horrible at least
be tall my whole thing is that they're
all horrible hold up pause there so hold
on you're proving the point because
you're saying that you are more
attracted to tall men so unless you're
just saying I've been brainwashed by the
men who said the beauty standards then
you're saying no we do we prefer tall
men and so I hate all men but I find
tall men hotter so I'm going to go if I
have to be with a horrible man I'm gonna
be with the filming you're you're
undercutting the first part of your
argument
we've gotten to a point where like
romanticizing obesity is okay
what do you think it's like like
genuinely what do you think it's like to
exist in a world where fat people are
like your biggest stressor
like you're not a fat person but your
mind is so consumed by their existence
the Earth is like literally on fire
minorities are losing rights like every
Sunday people are being murdered in the
street and you moved that billboard to
the top of your priority list
get a job
[Laughter]
have you ever thought about like when
you see something you don't like you do
this
mind your business we have like real
problems to address this isn't one of
them bye
the laugh is very funny the laugh is
very funny and the irony of course to
this commentary is that you're saying
this this woman this fat person is in
your mind if fat people are occupying
your mind and causing you to focus on a
lot and resent them then you're a
complete loser but of course she is
guilty of that with regard to white
people because their next sentence
because minorities are having their
rights taken away by the evil white man
maybe we've been white people are
terrible so she's just she's just
focusing and obsessing over white people
or men too is the other the other
disfavored group by her so it's ironic
and she's probably probably not aware of
that
she's definitely aware of the laugh
though and she's aware that the laugh is
genuine funny I didn't I got a kick out
of it I gotta look credit where credits
too I got a kick out of her do y'all
want to hear something I find absolutely
hilarious no